Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 255. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich spreche in Mikrophone und werde versuchen, dieses Chaos Radio irgendwie ein bisschen zusammenzuhalten. Was kompliziert wird, weil we put the chaos back into the Chaos Communication Congress, weil der ist ja unfassbar gut organisiert dieses Jahr. Ich habe für das Ticket einlösend irgendwie weniger als zehn Minuten angestanden. Es gab keine Schlange, wenn man, als ich mein Decktelefon registrieren wollte. Das wird heute hier ein bisschen anders. Wir haben es wie immer gemacht auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, nämlich uns ein paar Sachen rausgesucht, wo wir dachten, wollen wir mal gerne darüber sprechen, weil das klingt ganz interessant. Das hat aber dieses Jahr so funktioniert, dass ich schon Dinge gesehen habe, das aber nicht die Dinge sind, über die wir heute sprechen. Das heißt, ich versuche ja immer für Hörerinnen und Hörer am Start zu sein und das Unwissen in Wissen zu verwandeln. Das passiert tatsächlich heute bei mir auch live. Herzlich willkommen auch dazu. Und ganz am Ende der Sendung, das kann ich schon mal ankündigen, werde ich etwas über die Zukunftspläne des Chaosradios sagen. Da könnt ihr schon mal sehr, sehr gespannt sein. So, die erste Gästin heute ist Anne Roth. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Du bist Referentin für Netzpolitik bei den Linken. Im Bundestag und Netzaktivistin, Stammgästin beim Chaosradio. Du musst immer was sagen, weil wenn du es siehst, das kann man im Radio überhaupt gar nicht. Sehr gut, alles. Und du hattest keinen Talk beim Kongress. Das ist nicht unwichtig, weil alle Themen, die wir heute machen, sind nicht nur inhaltlich von Interesse, sondern zeigen auch so ein bisschen, wie der Chaos-Kongress funktioniert, abseits der großen Dinge, die man überall lesen kann. Also es gibt ja zum Chaos-Kongress immer auch die großen Sachen, die passieren. Also das ist dieses Jahr die Gesundheitsakte, die möglicherweise nicht ganz so sicher ist, wie sich das bestimmte Leute gedacht haben. Und dann gab es diese Geschichte mit Finspy und Finfisher. Also da hat anscheinend eine, anscheinend sollen deutsche Programmierer an Überwachungssoftware mitgearbeitet haben, was eigentlich so hätte gar nicht geschehen dürfen. Und dann gibt es diese Tracks auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, wo wichtige Menschen wichtige Dinge sagen. Und dann gibt es aber auch Themen, die passieren einfach so. Dein Thema war auch so eins.
Kona ist ein kollektiver Ansatz, sich zu organisieren, Stimmung, Verantwortung mit dem Ego zurück zu schrauben, zuhören, zuhören, aufpassen, die paar Streiten und Lieben gleichzeitig zu teilen.
Aber die Frage, die ich dann an der Stelle hätte, ist, wenn alle immer durcheinander reden, wie funktioniert das denn?
Das ist mich erstaunlich.
Komplexes Zuhören. Komplexes Zuhören, komplexes Sprechen. Viel zu weniger. Viel zu leise eigentlich.
Das ist interessant, weil mir erzählen oft Leute, sie würden Podcasts zum Einschlafen hören, was ich total unfassbar finde, weil ich das selber nicht kann. Wenn eine Stimme verständliche Worte redet, dann muss ich dazuhören und kann dabei unmöglich einschlafen. Aber dieses Susurum von der Stimme fand ich sehr beruhigend. Dieses Mikrofon hier scheint mir gar nicht anzusehen. Könnten wir da vielleicht noch mal sagen? Noch eine Stimme.
Dann hat eins ja gar nicht gehört, wie du vorhin von den Handstandinnen gesprochen hast.
Ja, ich hab sie nicht von den Handstandinnen erzählt.
Und von den Männern.
Ja, Komona besteht hauptsächlich aus Feuerwehrmännerinnen, Pfotzen und Pfotzeninnen und Pfotzausen.
Das scheint mir eine bunte Truppe, wenn ich das mal so garnehme. Aber ok, da scheint nicht klarbar ist, was das ist. Vielleicht im Rahmen des Kongresses, wo ist denn eins Komona hier? Und wie sieht es aus?
Das ist ein Pizzastück, da könnt ihr vorbeikommen, mitessen und mitmachen.
Wo denn?
Also es ist so eine Ansammlung von verschiedenen Spaces in Halle 2. Ihr findet das auch über die Navigations-App tatsächlich unter 1 Komona. Und es ist ein schöner Ort, also wir laden euch alle ein, da mal vorbeizukommen und einfach die verschiedenen Initiativen, die es dort gibt, auch kennenzulernen und einfach mitzumachen, weil wie gesagt wurde bei der Komona geht es sehr viel um Organisierung und das ist ein offenes Prozess. Also Selbstorganisierung ist auch etwas, was wir alle lernen wollen und müssen.
Wie gut funktioniert das?
Also ich hatte gestern um 4.00 Uhr früh voll den Aufräumdrang und hab einfach die Bierflaschen aufgeräumt. Das war eigentlich ganz okay.
Also es gibt ungefähr 732, 2 Pets, in denen irgendwelche Informationen stehen. Und die haben auch alle mehrere Passwörter. Und nur manche Leute haben auch Zugang zu diesen Passwörtern und andere Leute haben Zugang zu diesen Pets.
Also eigentlich haben schon alle Zugänge zu allen, aber man muss sich drum kümmern.
Aber eigentlich ist letzten Endes noch ganz egal, was da steht.
Ja, weil wenn wir da sind, dann ist es eh egal.
Ist es ein Projekt, das nur dem Ergründen der Möglichkeiten und Unmöglichkeiten von Selbstorganisation dient? Oder gibt es auch Dinge, die ihr außer die Möglichkeiten und Unmöglichkeiten von Selbstorganisation mit dem Publikum auf dem Chaos Communication Congress teilen wollt?
Ich glaube nicht an das Konzept von Publikum.
Also der Punkt ist halt, in dem Moment, in dem du einen Comuna betrittst, bist du auch Teil von Comuna. Ein Raum, eine Situation ist immer von allen getragen, die in dem Moment da sind. So wie wir jetzt alle in dem Raum auch Teil von diesem Gespräch sind. Und irgendwie funktioniert das in Comuna nicht so gut mit einfach kommen und konsumieren.
Also ich glaube, dass jeder, der oder die in Comuna betritt, ganz viel Inhalt mitbringt. Und natürlich ist die Challenge die Selbstorganisation von ganz viel Inhalten davon.
Also ich glaube, wenn so dieser Anspruch von Dezentralisierung irgendwie ernst genommen werden soll, dann heißt das ja, dass ganz viele Leute befähigt sind, sich auch dezentral zu organisieren. Das ist ja auch so ein Anspruch.
Also wenn man das aus der technischen Perspektive betrachtet, funktioniert die Dezentralisierung vor allen Dingen dadurch, dass man sich auf Protokolle geeignet hat, also auf eine gemeinsame Sprache, die man spricht. Und die im technischen Sinne für alle dasselbe bedeutet. Das scheint mir jetzt hier nicht so toll der Fall zu sein.
Ja, es gibt jeden Abend ein Plenum, aber da geht auch eigentlich nicht so viele Leute hin. Wir versuchen das so weit zu dezentralisieren, dass wir ein delegiertes System hätten, wo quasi Leute als verschiedenen Infinity Groups ihre Abgesandten ans Plenum schicken können und die dann wieder zurückreporten können. Aber das mit der gemeinsamen Sprache nun Menschen sind ja zum Glück keine Technik. Und damit das Menschsein besonders gut funktioniert, ist es wichtig, Strukturen zu erschaffen, in denen mit verschiedenen Sprachen gearbeitet werden kann. Und eine dezentrale Struktur, die das Menschsein ernst nimmt, hat keine gemeinsame Sprache.
Aber ist es da noch eine Struktur?
Es ist halt was anderes. Es ist so ein flexibles Ding aus verschiedenen Beziehungen.
Was mir tatsächlich ein bisschen komisch vorkommt, ist, dass mir gefühlt die ganze Zeit erklärt wird, warum das keine funktionierende, festgelegte Struktur oder Kommunikation ist. Warum gibt es dann überhaupt diesen Ort und diesen Namen, der ja etwas vereinigt, was es eigentlich gar nicht zu geben scheint?
Doch, es gibt schon einen zusammen. Und das ist halt einfach, dass sich darauf einigen, dass man diesen Ort bespielt. Und darauf zu einigen, dass jeder dieser Gruppen, die dort einen Ort bespielt, es gibt ja verschiedene Bereiche, verschiedene sozusagen Doms oder Zonen oder Orte, die von unterschiedlichen Gruppen genutzt bespielt werden, dass sozusagen der gemeinsame Verantwortung für diesen Ort sozusagen übernommen wird und dass auch Leute, die dazukommen, eingeladen werden, mit Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Also das ist vielleicht so etwas, was schon so eine Art Grundsatz ist. Also das sozusagen wie diesen be excellent to each other. Also dass wir das halt auf diesen Ort umlegen und sagen, ja, diese Zone, die eine Kommune für uns ist, ist ein Ort, wo wir wirklich gut miteinander umgehen wollen und wo verschiedene Gruppen sich dazu committen, gemeinsam Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Und gerade das mit dem vereinheitlichten Namen, das geht ja vor allem um Ansprechbarkeit von außen. Nach innen geht es ja nicht da. Also, damit von außen über was geredet werden kann, braucht es ja ein Wort. Und gegen innen hin ist es ja erstmal egal, ob man ein gemeinsames Wort hat oder nicht. Viel wichtiger ist der gemeinsame Wille.
Das finde ich das verwundere, weil es gibt dieses gemeinsame Wort. Und wegen des gemeinsamen Wortes seid ihr jetzt auch hier. Aber jede Frage, die man stellt, im Versuch, das gemeinsame Wort zu verstehen, wird damit beantwortet, es gibt nichts gemeinsames, was wir so erklären können, dass es dieses Wort erklärt. Das ist mein Verständnisproblem an der Stelle.
Ich komme gerade aus einem zweistündigen Workshop, der hieß, Comuna, What is it even? Und es sind sehr verschiedene Antworten dabei rausgekommen. Das Comuna existiert nicht seit, oder ja, nein, beides gleichzeitig, seit jetzt fast drei Jahren. Und darin gibt es aber, es gibt eine Kontinuität und gleichzeitig gibt es sie halt auch nicht. Also genauso wie der Kongress eine Kontinuität hat und gleichzeitig halt auch nicht. Also es geht ja quasi darum, es gibt nicht nur Zeit und Raum, sondern es gibt ja auch als dritte Konstituente quasi die Beziehungsweisen, die zwischen den Menschen entstehen, die Arten des Umgangs miteinander. Und das ist irgendwie das, was sich halt für eine Sprache fassen lässt, weil das etwas ist, worüber noch nicht so viel gesprochen wird oder was noch nicht so, was auch etwas ist, was sich die ganze Zeit verändert und was aber genauso eine Situation mitbestimmt wie Raum und Zeit.
Aber es ist, im Endeffekt ist Komono ja auch nicht so abstrakt. Es ist tatsächlich ein sehr realer Ort, wo initiativen Dinge tun und wo einfach Sachen passieren. Also es gibt dort einfach auch Spaces für Workshops, es gibt verschiedene Gruppen, die bestimmte Dinge vermitteln wollen und das ist dann wieder das sehr Konkretes und es geht natürlich darum, dieses Miteinander zueinander zu verhandeln und ja, gut, das halt gut zu machen. Und halt so zu machen, wie wir uns auch Gesellschaft vorstellen. Also zum Beispiel halt solidarisch.
So langweilig, dieses ganze ernste Gelaber hier.
Man würde die Kritik an dem Gelaber viel besser verstehen, wenn du den Mikrofon nicht immer wegmachen würdest. Du bist auch von der technischen Struktur, das tut mir sehr leid, aber du musst dich hier unterwerfen, wenn du gehört werden willst.
Also konkret gehört werden möchtest.
Ja, ich finde es gerade ein bisschen zu ernst. Und so ein bisschen, glaube ich, ist es auch ganz okay, dass das so ephämie ist.
Aber ich frage mich, wie inklusiv ist das? Also wenn ihr in ein Ort sein wolltet...
Bloß nicht inklusiv, das bedeutet immer exklusiv zu sein.
Warum?
Ja, inklusiv, exklusiv.
Du kannst natürlich den Satz nochmal wiederholen, aber warum? Warum ist es sozusagen exklusiv, wenn man...
Weil inklusiv davon ausgeht, dass wir gleich sein können. Und wir können alle nicht gleich sein.
Das ist nun alle unterschiedlich.
Okay, halt, ich bin jetzt auf einer Diskussion. Ich denke, ich hätte das eher verstanden als, ihr wolltet ein Ort sein, also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ein Ort sein, wo man auch hinkommen kann und dann tatsächlich auch Teil dieses Ortes ist. Das kann man natürlich Qualdefinition immer festlegen und sagen, wenn du hier bist, dann bist du auch da. Aber ich freu mich natürlich schon, wenn man zu so einem Ort kommt, wie befremdlich und damit sozusagen abstoßend wirkt das. Also im Sinne von, dass ich mich meiner selbst gar nicht angenommen fühle an diesem Ort, der eigentlich für alle da sein will. Und welche Rolle das für euch spielt, ob dieses Gefühl ausgelöst wird oder nicht. Gesellschaftlicher Konsens. Frieden auf der Welt durch Bällebad. Das könnte funktionieren. Ein paar Sachen hab ich gehört. Es gibt bei euch eine Polizeiklasse.
Todesleite, ja.
Was ist das und warum?
Es gibt die Polizeiklasse. Ein interdisziplinäres Künstlerinnen-Kollektiv. Aufgrund der neuen Polizeiaufgabengesetze, die 2017 und 2018 in Bayern novelliert worden sind. Jetzt auch auf andere Bundesländer zu kommen werden. Oder auch schon umgesetzt worden sind. Diese Gruppierung hat sich vorgenommen, in so legalen Bereichen und gewaltfrei zu intervenieren. In öffentlichen Raum. Und das sichtbar zu machen. Also eher so eine Informationsoffensive und Mobi-Aktionen zu planen.
Ich finde schon, dass wir das nur machen, weil es cool ist.
Also würdet ihr sagen, die Polizeiklasse ist eher so peng oder eher Political Beauty?
Beides überhaupt nicht, weil das Zeital neoliberalisiert ist.
Sondern?
Es geht vielmehr um eine Bewegung eigentlich. Es geht darum, die Politisierung weiter voranzutreiben. Deswegen müssen wir Mittel und Wege finden, künstlerische Werkzeuge an die Hand zu geben, die vervielfältigbar sind und auch nicht irgendwie ein großartig, unglaublich schön designtes Mahnmal vor dem Bundestag darstellen, das unglaublich aufwändige Planung braucht und Ressourcen, sondern die Kunst ist eine Verbündete von uns allen. Und deswegen müssen wir uns beibringen, sie alle zu nutzen. Und es geht nicht darum, dass man ganz designt einfach nur...
Ja, und es geht halt wahrscheinlich auch um Sprache oder den Versuch... Sprache ist auch exklusiv wahrscheinlich, aber Bilder wahrscheinlich auch. Aber auch Menschen zu erreichen, die vielleicht gewohnte Bilder aus einer eher linken oder anarchischen Strömung nicht so verstehen oder nicht annehmen können. Und die möchte man ja erreichen, damit die auch anfangen, darüber nachzudenken, ob sie Teil sein möchten von einer Gewaltfreien Gesellschaft.
Ist das noch Konzeptarbeit oder habt ihr schon ein Beispiel für sozusagen so ein künstlerisches Werkzeug, das man an die Hand geben kann?
Was supergut ist, jeder von uns hat zum Beispiel Bluetooth-Boxen und jeder von uns hat einen Computer und kann so ein Mikro oder so ein Ding, was du da auch hast, ja an den Kopf schnallen und mal so einen Text einsprechen. Und das kann ja jegliche Forderung sein, ich hoffe, ich will, dass die Leute einfach ein bisschen mehr pupsen in der U-Bahn oder so oder sich einfach ein bisschen anders entspannen oder tatsächlich, wenn sie wirklich politische Forderungen haben, können sie das ja auch irgendwie verschriftlichen und vertonen und das zum Beispiel mit ihren Freunden in der U-Bahn teilen über diese besagten Bluetooth-Lautsprecher. Super simpel, funktioniert, kotzt einige Leute an, ziemlich witzig, macht Spaß.
Also ganz ehrlich, bis jetzt kommt es mir so vor, als ob es vor allen Dingen um Irritation geht.
Ich glaube, wenn es die richtigen Inhalte sind, dann geht es natürlich in gewisser Weise darum, diese Bubbles und diese kleinen Tunnel, in denen man sich im Alltag bewegt, zu stören. Und das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so unwichtig, weil...
Nee, das ist ab... Ich verstehe sozusagen, dass man das so definieren kann. Aber es kommt mir so vor, als ginge es um die Irritation der Irritation willen. Nee, wir haben ja auch... Zum Beispiel für alle, die Podcast nur hören und nicht sehen. Im Hintergrund wälzen sich gerade so zwei oder drei Leute, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, herum. Ich kenne die auch nicht. Und strecken ihre Füße in die Luft. Das sind möglicherweise schöne Füße, aber es hat halt sozusagen an sich, für mich zumindest, keine Aussage, sondern es ist vor allen Dingen eine Irritation. Die aber den Zweck einer Irritation hat und sonst nichts. Und so kommt mir das halt auch vor, momentan.
Aber wenn du sagst und sonst nichts, dann klingt das ja so sehr erwärtend auf mich jetzt gerade. Und ich frage mich, was wäre denn dieses sonst, was du erwartest?
Einen Beitrag zu der Sendung, die wir hier machen. Machen wir doch. Ich verstehe diesen Beitrag nicht, deswegen kommen sie sofort.
Also ich hab einfach keine Ahnung vom Kunst vielleicht. Aber Irritation und Provokation sind einfach ein paar gewisse Stilmittel, die man anwenden kann. Und man kann Sachen appropriieren. Und es gibt so viele wiege, Gewege künstlerisch zu agieren. Und das ist jetzt die Irritation, die Irritation will. Und das ist die Irritation, die man sich anwenden kann. Ach, wenn da auf einmal Flugblätter von Münchner Rathaus fliegen, die einfach auf eine Demo hinweisen und die neuen Polizeiaufgabengesetze, dann ist das schon recht informativ und dadurch, dass man das dann halt im heutigen Zeitalter natürlich auch ein bisschen frameen kann und es soziale Medien gibt, auf denen man das teilen kann, kann man dadurch viel mehr Leute erreichen und vielleicht auch mit einem gewissen Charme letztendlich auch Leute erreichen, die sich nicht ansonsten für dieses Thema interessiert hätten. Dafür zum Beispiel haben wir dieses, ich hab vielleicht überall diese Nein-Sticker gesehen hier, haben wir so ein Label entworfen, dass es dadurch entstanden ist. So was ist der Slogan, den wir nutzen können, um dem ganzen irgendwie vielleicht so ein bisschen mehr Pepp zu geben? Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, nein. So vier Worte, ganz klar, meine ich doch. Ist alles das gleiche. Inklusiv, exklusiv, aber ja. Und dann haben die gesagt, ne, finden sie alle scheiße. Und deswegen haben wir es einfach selber gemacht. Und jetzt findet sich dieses Nein halt doch wieder. Das dürfen auch alle Leute benutzen. Das findet ihr auf unserer Webseite polizeiklasse.org. Da könnt ihr das Nein herunterladen, es vervielfältigen, es in andere Kontexte mit einbringen, euch fetzige T-Shirts drucken oder euch das Gesicht tätowieren, wie auch immer.
Das Nein herunterladen, das find ich auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr, sehr schöner Satz.
Oder halt so konkretere Sachen wie die cop-map.de, Menschen, die von Polizeigewalt oder Repression jeden Tag betroffen sind, nur weil sie nicht weiß sind oder so, einfach unterstützen und helfen, damit sie wissen, wo ist jetzt gerade die Polizei, wo kann ich sie jetzt vermeiden, sodass sie ganz schnell in die Arbeit kommen, ohne Verspätung. Gibt's auch. Das habe ich mit dem Pengel zusammen gemacht. Die haben dann auch Ressourcen und Wissen. Man geht in Zusammenarbeit oder Austausch. Man kann sich auch gegenseitig unterstützen als Gruppierungen.
Und die Polizeiklasse ist also ein Bewohner, das ist eigentlich ein kollektiven Ort. Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Jemand hat heute geschrieben, eine Intergalactic Dome Exhibition.
Okay, also die Polizeiklasse ist ein Aufstellungsstück in der Intergalactic Dome Exhibition. Was gibt es noch?
Das ist kein Stück, ja.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel...
Was sind die Bestandteile einer Exhibition?
Nein, wir sind so nicht da.
Wir bewegen uns.
Aber lassen wir doch die anderen auch mal sprechen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel die Spieleberatung, es gibt zum Beispiel auch Reclaim Club Culture und Chaos Ballett. Und die Dezentrale als Ort, wo die sich treffen. Magst du was sagen zum Chaos Ballett?
Ich mag was sagen zu Reclaim Club Culture. Das ist ein Bündnis von Clubbetreiberinnen, Aktivistinnen, Menschen, die im Clubs in Berlin mostly arbeiten, dann Forscherinnen und das Netzwerk ist angetreten, um emanzipatorische Praxis in der Clubkultur einen Diskussionsraum zu geben. Und hat dann 2018 eine Demonstration namens AFD Wegbassen initiiert, wo auf einmal die gesamte alternative, ein bisschen schwieriges Wort, aber alternative Club Szene in Berlin aktiv wurde und 70.000 Leute mobilisiert hat, um gegen die AFD zu demonstrieren in einem politischen Klima, wo die traditionelle Linke, zu der ich mich nicht zählen will, oder wir uns nicht nicht zählen will, ein Mobilisierungsproblem hatte und wir durch einen alternativen Gesellschaftsentwurf sehr viel bunten Protest, diversen Protest auf die Straße getragen haben und seitdem nicht nur innerhalb der Clubkultur aktiv sind, sondern auch außerhalb und Protest auf die Straße tragen, um auch klar zu machen, was haben wir auch durch einen Rechtsruck zu verlieren und wie können wir antifaschistische Kämpfe in Räume, die es vielleicht vorher nicht betroffen hat, wieder klar machen. Und da ist ja auch letztes Jahr auch am CCC die Diskussion durch die Platzierung der Antifa Flagge im Eingang aufgekommen. Und das sehe ich halt so als Räume, wo irgendwie andere Lebensentwürfe gelebt werden. Die sind jetzt auch an dem Punkt, wo wir uns irgendwie zu positionieren müssen. Um gegen eine Faschistisierung der Gesellschaft zu arbeiten. Und da arbeiten wir in ganz unterschiedlichen Kontexten. Also wir sind sehr viel aktivistisch unterwegs, aber wir arbeiten auch in die Community rein um Themen wie Erwähnnis und Themen wie, wie können wir uns vor Polizeirepressionen auf linke Strukturen schützen? Also wie können wir auch, es geht auch sehr viel um Wissenstransfer. Wir arbeiten sehr viel mit How-To's, um Menschen zu ermöglichen, wie sie oder dass, dass sie auch Dinge tun können. Also da gibt es überhaupt keine Autorinnenschaft, deswegen sitze ich jetzt als Person auch, für alle die es nicht sehen, sehr verkleidet hier, weil ich heute also Rosa Rafe hier bin, die antifaschistische Clubaktivistin aus der Zukunft, die eine kollektive Stimme ist und von sehr unterschiedlichen Personen in unterschiedlichen Rollen gespielt wird. Und heute bin ich eben die, die es spielt.
Das Reclaim the Club Culture bezieht sich also darauf, dass die sozusagen Räume der Unterhaltung und des hedonismus wieder antifaschistisch werden? Oder geht es auch um die Strukturen, in denen Club leben? Also weil du jetzt Berlin als Beispiel oder ihr Berlin als Beispiel angebracht habt, geht es auch darum?
Na ja, also Club Kultur ist ja tatsächlich gegründet worden oder entstanden, durch ein Begehren, alternative Lebenskonzepte zu leben.
Wenn man so sagt, aus der Stadtperspektive, das rechnet sich ja gerade nicht mehr.
Genau, es gibt ja gerade und deswegen sage ich ja auch, wir sind sehr in Berlin aktiv. Es gibt ja gerade in Berlin doch durchaus noch einige Clubs und Strukturen, die nicht auf Verwertung aus sind, sondern eben kollektiv organisiert sind, was mega anstrengend ist, was mega viel Zeit braucht, was auch keinerlei großen Profit irgendwie abwirft. Aber diese Orte gibt es noch und diese Orte sind von Gentrifizierung enorm bedroht. Das ist auch ein Thema, an dem wir sehr viel arbeiten. Linke und alternative Orte im stadtpolitischen Kontext, deren Wichtigkeit sozusagen eine Lobby zu geben, weil es einfach wirklich wie eine Schneelawine, das ist Neoliberalismus sozusagen, diese Orte auch bedroht sind. Und da geht es wirklich um Mietverträge, da geht es um, wenn ich mich entscheide, nicht meine Getränke zu sponsern, sondern einfach nur Getränke verkaufen will, dann habe ich halt schon einen Wettbewerbsnachteil. Und es sind wirklich kleine Dinge. Und diese Orte, die sich aber im Reclaim Club Culture vernetzen, versuchen eben nicht nur auf diese consumer orientierte Club Kultur, also sich davon abzugrenzen. Und eben wie Comona auch, alle Personen, die an einem Abend in den Club kommen, sind nicht nur Consumer, sondern es geht um be excellent to each other, es geht wirklich um Prinzipien zu leben und sich ausprobieren zu können dadurch, weil wir gut zueinander sind.
Was ich hier so ein bisschen durchsitze, ich hab das Einschlag auch noch gehört, was mich persönlich auch interessiert, Spieleberatung. Kann mir dazu jemand was erklären? Na ja, es geht um Spiele anscheinend. Spielen finde ich interessant. Was macht das in dem Kontext? Was ist die Spieleberatung? Wen berät sie, was zu spielen?
Ja, die Spieleberatung ist vor allem erst mal eine Art zu denken. Und wir beschäftigen uns ganz doll mit Kommunikationsstrukturen, mit Sprache, mit Narrativ und mit Regeln. Also alles das, was quasi ein Spiel in seinen einzelnen Teilen ausmacht. Und das fließt dann auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen in verschiedene Umgebungen ein. Und das schafft so Spielräume, also die Möglichkeit überhaupt ins Spiel zu kommen. Wem berät die Spieleberatung? Ja, große Frage. Also eigentlich alle, die wollen oder die spielen wollen oder nicht spielen wollen, können sich beraten lassen. Aber das klingt dann halt so direkt nach so einer hierarchischen Situation. Meistens ist es eigentlich so, dass die Konzepte oder die, wenn man das jetzt Spiele nennen will, die Spiele der Spieleberatung darauf ausgelegt sind, dass sie eigentlich selber von den Spielenden mitgestaltet werden können. Also weil das eigentlich am Spielen, im Englischen gibt es da die schöne Unterscheidung zwischen Game and Play und das schöne am Spielen ist eigentlich das Spannende, ist ja immer dann, wenn ich in der Position bin, dass ich die Regeln während ich spiele ändere.
Das ist dann also eher das Play, das freie Spiel.
Das freie Spiel.
Das Regellose.
Nee, ist eben nicht regellos. Das ist ja das Interessante. Das Regel Dynamische, also die Regeln brechen sich quasi immer selbst, also das merkt man ja, wenn man selbst in so einem Alltagsspiel drin ist, weiß eins ja auch nicht so genau, wo das jetzt hinführt. Also nicht das zielorientierte Spielen, sondern...
Das klingt sehr spannend, das klingt vor allen Dingen auch, dass man sozusagen den ganzen Kongress auch einfach in eins Komuna zubringen könnte und dann trotzdem noch nicht fertig wäre im Sinne von jedes Projekt gesehen zu haben, was da...
Ich glaube deswegen kommen wir auch immer wieder zurück, weil wir halt nie fertig sind.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Kurz ein Element, was auch noch eben im Komuna Platz hat, ist eben der Info-Laden. Und das ist irgendwie vielleicht auch nochmal ein recht zentrales Element, weil was jetzt auch immer wieder gekommen ist, ist sozusagen die Frage von Wissenswiedergabe und auch irgendwie Wissenssammlung. Und wir sind halt so ein Ort, also wir sammeln halt Wissen und schauen, dass das wirklich halt Informationen möglichst vielen Menschen möglichst niederschwellig zugänglich gemacht werden. Und das halt in einer relativ Papierform eigentlich, also gar nicht digital. Das ist vielleicht, wir sind auch so ein bisschen wenig digital, sehr analog sozusagen. Aber tatsächlich hat einfach, was wir halt machen als Kollektiv, wir sind halt in verschiedenen Städten europaweit organisiert, ist halt genau diese Ansätze von Selbstorganisierung, diese Ansätze von aktivistischen Strategien, auch von Widerstand, von den verschiedenen Kämpfen halt zusammenzutragen und halt immer mit uns mitzutragen und an andere Orte zu bringen. Und einer dieser Orte, auf denen wir halt aufschlagen, ist halt der CCC, weil wir halt diese Frage von Technologie und wie gemeinsamer Umgang mit Technologie und wie ein guter Umgang mit Technologie aussehen kann, halt für sehr wichtig befinden. Und weil wir auch alle mit Technologie irgendwie arbeiten, was ja irgendwie Gesellschafts jetzt nicht mehr in eine Situation kommen wird, wo es ohne Technologie läuft, sondern einfach die Frage ist, wie kann die gestaltet werden? Genau, und wir bringen uns da halt auch ein. Also wir sind dann halt auch Teil von eins Kommune und haben halt diesen Anlaufpunkt, wo halt Leute gerne vorbeikommen können, selber Material bringen können. Wir tragen das weiter und sich Material holen können. Und das ist dann halt in verschiedensten Formen. Das sind Scenes, das sind Bücher, also viel sozusagen inoffizielle Literatur, das sind Sticker, das sind Plakate, das ist auch eine Datenbank von Materialien, die es genauso bei uns dann halt gibt. Ja, und da laden wir halt auch alle ein, sozusagen ihre Content, ihre Informationen einzubringen und das halt zu teilen, weil halt irgendwie Wissensteilen und Informationen weitertragen und diese Konzepte, die es halt gibt, an andere weitergeben, ist halt sehr wichtig.
Ja, die Couch dazwischen. Wenn ich vielleicht kurz auf all das eingehen darf, ich glaube, ich hatte gestern ein Gespräch, wo mir noch mal aufgegangen ist, was hat irgendwie so ein krasser Unterschied, also was bei Einskommunas so anders ist. Es sind nicht Tische, an denen die Leute sind und für sich arbeiten und du gehst ihnen hin, sondern eigentlich sind wir alles Kollektive und die Gesamtstruktur ist so aufgebaut, dass sie halt eben zur Verfügung steht und gekommen werden kann.
Also du gehst in so einen Raum rein und trittst dann ein Gespräch mit Menschen und da sitzt doch niemand hinter einem Tisch, sondern das ist eher so ein gemeinsamer Platz, wo du dich halt dazusetzen kannst.
Oder dich einbuchen kannst mit irgendwelchen Workshops, also das ist ja auch mega offen, das kann ja jede Person machen und da gibt es auch kein, also ich denke mal gegen faschistische Workshops würden wir uns jetzt wehren, aber ansonsten gibt es ja keine Regelungen, wer wo was machen kann, sondern es ist halt ein Möglichkeitsraum.
Man muss auch den Einskommuner gar nicht verlassen, weil dann ist ein Tag vorbei, weil den ganzen Tag in der Kommunikation mit so vielen Menschen war es, aus den verschiedensten Städten, über verschiedenste aktivistische Formen, über verschiedenste Sachen, die sie machen, dass du halt schon eigentlich super fit bist nach einem ganzen Tag und dann halt erst die Forte oder die Halle wieder verlässt, um was Neues wieder aufnehmen zu können einfach, weil das so viel gesellschaftstheoretischen, alternativen Input auch beinhaltet. Also allein schon, dass zum Beispiel die Hambi-Leute da irgendwie einen Baum oder einen Kletterpoint simuliert haben, was für die Kinder auch super wichtig und super toll ist, halt diesen alternativen Gesellschaftsentwurf, deine Naturrettung halt auch kennenzulernen. Das ist einwandfrei. Also wo finden wir das sonst?
Ich finde es total spannend, dass bei den ersten beiden Sachen, die wir jetzt hier hatten, fand ich es wichtig, den digitalen Anknüpfungspunkt zu nennen. Aber hier würde ich echt sagen, geht mal vorbei. Also hier auf dem Kongress, aber trotzdem noch die Frage, trotzdem, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, ihr seid gar nicht so digital. Gibt es die Intergalactic Domain Exhibition auch online? Aber gibt es sozusagen, gibt es ein Tor in die Hölle, ein Tor in die Pads? Wie heißt der?
Hashtag Comuna Doppelpunkt, ganz viele verschiedene Server. Aber ich glaube, er ist auch über den Matrix Server erreichbar.
Ihr habt keine Website?
Nein, tatsächlich ist es halt einfach, die Initiativen stehen für sich und wir sind beim Kongress halt zusammen.
Ach so, ich hatte verstanden, das sind verschiedene Städte auch.
Es sind Leute aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Städten. Es sind Leute aus Vilnius, es sind Leute aus Wien, es sind Leute aus Hamburg, aus Berlin, aus...
München...
.München, aus... keine Ahnung.
Dann würde ich sagen, besucht die 1 Comuna, wo ihr sie findet. Und an dieser Stelle würde ich erst mal sagen, vielen Dank. Danke schön.
Heute findet kein Rave statt.
Heute findet kein Rave statt. So was. So, dann haben wir noch ein letztes Thema, einen letzten Beitrag. Und da geht es um Flipdots. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt. Da kommt jemand. Hallo, guten Tag. Bitte einfach am liebsten mich setzen hier hin. Das hat sich bewährt. Und jetzt ist jemand da, der etwas mitgebracht hat. Darf ich die Hardware anfassen?
Ja, die kannst du auf jeden Fall anfassen. Die kannst du auch ein bisschen auseinanderlegen. Ich habe hier mal so ein einzelnes Panel mitgebracht. Das macht es vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher.
Hi, wer bist du? Hi, Flippke. Du hast mir ein einzelnes Panel mitgebracht. Das setzt voraus, es gibt etwas, aus dem dieses Panel ein Bestandteil eines Ganzen ist?
Das ist richtig.
Was ist das Ganze?
Das Ganze ist ein Anzeiger, wo fünf Stück solcher Dinger drin sitzen. Und das ist in einer Tram montiert gewesen.
Also ich habe hier etwas in der Hand. Das hat Rechtecke, davon sind viele schwarz, eine wenige gelb. Es sieht aus wie eine Anzeigetafel, würde ich sagen. Ein einziges Rechteck ist ungefähr ein Zentimeter groß, Quadratzentimeter groß. Und da drin sind Spulen?
Genau, das ist ein elektromechanisches Display. Die sind vorne in den Trams drin gewesen und an den Seiten und haben ein Zugziel angezeigt. Wenn du das mal umdrehst, sollte da auch noch eine Jahreszahl draufstehen.
Hier steht quasi Linie 16, Messegelände.
Das würde da nicht draufstehen, weil sie aus Berlin kommen. Die sind von der BVG tatsächlich. Wenn du mal ein bisschen an der Kunstinstallation vorbeiläufst unter dem UV-Licht, kannst du tatsächlich auch noch...
Schub, schub, wir sind auf dem Kongress. Es gibt ja eine Kunstinstallation, die aus ehemaligen Anzeigetafeln der BVG entstanden ist.
Genau.
Du hast mir gesagt, ich soll eine Jahreszahl suchen. Ich guck mal, ich finde hier Dinge, die aussehen wie... 1530 wird es wahrscheinlich nicht gewesen sein.
Vermutlich nicht.
Ich bin überfordert, ich finde keine Jahreszahl, die eine sinnvolle Jahreszahl ist.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt auch ein schlechtes Modul mitgebracht, wo keine Jahreszahl draufsteht. Ich kann auch mal schauen. Es ist nicht durch die Qualitätskontrolle gelaufen.
Ein Modul ohne Jahreszahl, wie konnte das passieren? Aber apropos Jahreszahl, kehren wir zu den Anfängen zurück. Wie kommst du dazu, Anzeigetafeln von der BVG zu haben?
Ich wollte schon immer mal so Flipdots haben. Und dann hab ich diverse Anliegen.
Okay, Entschuldigung, ich muss schon wieder eine brechen. Kannst du kurz erklären, was ein Flipdot ist?
Ja, das ist das Ding, was wir uns hier gerade angeschaut haben.
Ein Flipdot ist sozusagen eines von diesen einzelnen Vier-Ecken? Oder Quadraten?
Ich würde die gesamte Technologie, die wir jetzt hier auf dem Tisch liegen haben, als Flipdot.
Aber das funktioniert so, das sind quasi kleine Plastekvadrate. Und die werden mechanisch umgeschaltet.
Genau, also wenn man sich das ganz genau anschaut, ist da drinnen noch so ein kleiner Magnet. Und wenn man das jetzt hier versucht, irgendwie so umzukippen, dann kippt das auch von alleine wieder zurück. Das heißt, das kann man nicht auch so runter machen. Das sind so kleine Plättchen. Die kippen dann so hin und her.
Na ja, und wenn sie aufgeklappt sind, sind sie gelb, und wenn sie zugeklappt sind, sind sie schwarz?
Ist das richtig?
Und du wolltest schon immer mal damit spielen? Wie kommt man dann so Zeug ran?
Ja, das fragen mich tatsächlich alle Leute. Wo hast du die her? Gibt es davon noch welche? Ja, ich hab tatsächlich sehr viele ÖPNV-Anbieter mal so angeschrieben und die gefragt, sag mal, habt ihr Flipdots? So auch bei der BVG, da einfach mal angerufen, Flipdots, was ist denn das?
Warte mal, das sind immer so die kleinen Details, die einfach mal angerufen, wen ruft man denn da an? Die zentrale Auskunftsnummer für den Fahrplan oder?
Das ist schon so lange her, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Also ich hatte da irgendeine Rufnummer von der BVG. Einfach mal angerufen, die dann so, ja, Flipdots, was ist denn das? Ah, okay, ja, da wenden sie sich mal irgendwie hier an die Instandhaltung. Das hab ich dann gemacht, dann kam dann irgendwann ein Anruf zurück. Ja, können sie haben. Und dann hab ich erst mal so... Ja, tatsächlich.
Kommen sie vorbei, holen sie ab oder wie lief es?
Genau, genau, so lief das. Ich hab sie dann tatsächlich per ÖPNV abgeholt, ein bisschen unterschätzt, wie schwer die Dinger tatsächlich sind.
Ich muss also für Baselinteressierte nicht unwichtige Fragen stellen. Die haben dir die einfach so gegeben oder du musstest die kaufen?
Ich habe sie gekauft, tatsächlich.
Für relevant Geld oder für... Wir nehmen einen symbolischen Betrag, weil es eher das Zeug ist, das wir wegwerfen wollen.
Na ja, also es kam dann halt so die Frage, was bezahle ich jetzt dafür? Was können sie bezahlen? Ja, das war damals aus dem studentischen Club heraus, den ich gemacht habe. Da hat man sich dann auf einen sehr geringen Betrag geeinigt. Dann hat man mir die in die Hand gedrückt. Was ein bisschen schwierig war, die können die nicht einfach so an Privatleute verkaufen, weil man dann halt sofort mit Haftung und so weiter mit drin ist. Das heißt, das war ein B2B-Verkauf.
Wenn die das als Privatperson verkauft hätten, hätten sie haften müssen, wenn dir das Ding auf die Füße fällt?
Nee, da sind ja einige auch kaputt. Dann hätten sie mir halt die Kaputten auch noch so austauschen. Also ich bin da nicht so 100 Prozent bewandert. Jedenfalls wollten sie mir das Ganze nur B2B verkaufen. Das war kein Thema.
Du hast da so eine Firma gegründet.
Ich bin ohnehin schon da ein bisschen länger als Freelancer in der IT unterwegs. Jedenfalls habe ich die Dinger dann gekauft. Erstmal zwei so große Anzeige. Und das ging dann so ein bisschen mit zum Selbststudium der Elektrotechnik einher. Und die Dinger dann reverse-ingeniert tatsächlich.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen.
Wenn man das Ding umdreht, dann ist ja hinten dran, sind Dinge, die kann ich als Leier, als Mikrochips identifizieren. Und da sind auch Dinge, die kann ich als Steckbleis identifizieren.
Das ist korrekt.
Da kann man einen Breitbandkabel anschließen. Also nicht Breitband im Sinne von Internet, sondern eines von diesen breiten Kabeln, wo man früher Festplatten computerfest gesteckt hat.
Das ist sehr IDI-ähnlich tatsächlich.
Gibt es da eine Programmiersprache, eine Schnittstelle?
Ja, also du siehst hier hinten drauf so zwei Transistor-Reiten. Das ist für jede Spalte, da sind so zwei Transistoren drauf. Und das sind letzten Endes die Spaltentreiber. Was die machen ist, die treiben mir die gesamte Spalte entweder gegen Ground oder gegen VCC, also plus 12 Volt in dem Fall. Und alles, was ich dann noch zur Verfügung stellen muss, sind dann halt die Zeilentreiber. Die Spaltentreiber sind hinten drauf. Und da schieb ich dann so einen Pixel-Takt rein. Und ich dampf jetzt gerade zwei Jahre.
Du redest jetzt aber in einer Sprache, die ich trotzdem nicht verstehe. Lass mich Fragen stellen. Also diese Dinger klappen um, wenn man Strom anlegt. Wenn du Strom anlegst, werden sie gelb.
Das kommt darauf an, in welche Richtung da der Strom fließt, ob sie dann gelb oder schwarz werden. Und es ist auch gar nicht mal so wenig Strom, den man da drauf geben muss. Also für die gesamte Wand, die da hier auf dem Congress steht, sind das tatsächlich 400 Ampere bei 12 Volt. Die hat mehr Leistung, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß, was sich da in Kühlschränken... Das C3 Power Top hat mir da so ein cooles Dashboard gebastelt, wie man sehen kann, wie viel Strom die ganze Installation verbraucht. Das kann man sich auch online anschauen, c3power.top. Das sind so 3 bis 4 kW, die da so durchgehen. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel, aber auf 12 Volt schon relativ viel Strom.
Diese Pixel musst du einzeln ansteuern?
Ich steuere das ganze Ding tatsächlich spaltenweise an, was auch erklärt, weshalb sich die Panels von oben nach unten updaten.
Du sagst immer Spalte gelb oder schwarz. Und dann machst du dasselbe für die rein und dadurch ergibt sich dann das Bild?
Nein, ich cleare zuerst die gesamte Spalte. Das heißt, ich setze die auf schwarz. Und im nächsten Takt übertrage ich dann über dieses breite Kabel, was da oben drauf geht, dann die Informationen, die Pixel-Daten so an die Spalte. Sodass ich eine gesamte Spalte auf einmal setzen kann.
Aber eine Spalte heißt, du sagst, für eine Spalte Pixel 1 schwarz, Pixel 2 weiß und so weiter und so fort. Dann gehst du einmal alle Spalten durch.
Genau, eine Spalte hat 16 Pixel und ich habe 115 Spalten pro Display. Das macht so auf die gesamte Installation, die ich da jetzt gerade in Betrieb habe, 576 x 230 Pixel, die ich darauf darstellen kann.
Und du kannst immer nur eine Spalte gleichzeitig beschicken?
Da ich da sehr viele Panels habe, also sehr viele so große.
Du kannst auf einem Panel immer nur eine Spalte gleichzeitig beschicken. Aber du kannst auf mehreren Panels jeweils eine Spalte beschicken.
Sodass ich halt insgesamt irgendwie so auf vier Frames in der Sekunde komme.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage, das hätte ich gewesen. Also ein moderner Monitor hat so mindestens 60 Hertz, manchmal 120.
Ja, da geht mehr so der Trend.
Du hast vier.
Ich hab vier.
Okay, was zum Standbilder anzeigen, also hervorragend geeignet. Machst du damit auch eine Animation?
Ja, also da hab ich mich tatsächlich erst ein bisschen schwergetan, weil halt Animationen darauf doch recht schwierig sind. Aber da kann man so ein bisschen mit Motionblur tricksen. Und wenn man dann halt so Bewegungen so ein bisschen blurry darstellt und ein bisschen mit Dizzering arbeitet, dann sieht das tatsächlich ganz cool aus und macht auch so ganz coole Geräusche. Weil das Display macht ja andere Geräusche, wenn irgendwie so viele Pixel so per Dizzering setzt, sieht das anders aus, hört sich das anders an, als wenn du alle einmal so rums auf einmal weiß oder schwarz setzt.
Kannst du Dizzering erklären, oder ist mir der Kopf platzt?
Na ja, die Displays, die ich hier habe, wie du gerade gesehen hast, die können ja nur schwarz oder weiß darstellen. Und damit ich so Halbtöne darstellen kann, könnte ich jetzt entweder den Pixel ganz schnell hin und her kippen lassen. Das würde funktionieren, wenn ich die Ansteuerung anders gestalten würde. Ja, darunter würden die Geräte wahrscheinlich ganz schön leiden. Oder was man auch machen kann, ist, dass ich einfach in einem Kasten von 2x2 Pixel dann halt nur 2 Pixel auf weiß stelle. Sodass halt insgesamt, wenn man Abstand von dem Ganzen nimmt, so der Eindruck von einer zweiten Farbe entsteht.
Also quasi ein Pixel sind vier von diesen Kästchen und die schaltest du dann teilweise um und hast so graue Stufen.
Genau so, genau so tatsächlich.
Musstest du denen noch Technik dazu bauen?
Tatsächlich ja. Also diese gesamten Anzeiger kommen mit einem uralten Mainboard daher. Da sitzt noch so ein richtig alter, fetter EEPROM tatsächlich drin. Also so ein steinalter Speicher, wo noch so Grafiken, Symbole und Zeichensätze von der BVG drinne waren, um halt irgendwie dann so anzuzeigen M8 nach sonst wohin. Und die habe ich allerdings tatsächlich alle rausgeworfen und dafür habe ich dann eine eigene Platine entwickelt.
Hast du einen Backup gemacht?
Natürlich. Das gesamte Projekt ist Open Source, also die Hardware ist dokumentiert. Ich habe die Platine, die wir uns jetzt hier gerade angeschaut haben, die da hinten draufhuckepackt ist, die ist dokumentiert.
Aber ist die dokumentiert im Sinne von, du hast die auseinandergenommen und dann dokumentiert oder hast du die selber gebaut?
Nee, die habe ich auseinandergenommen, um zu verstehen, wie das Ding funktioniert. Und dann habe ich sie in einem Schaltplantool dokumentiert, wie sie funktioniert, damit andere Leute, denen ich so ein Ding in die Hand drücke, auch wissen, wie man irgendwie da auch eigene Dinge verbasten kann. Und dann habe ich noch ein eigenes Mainboard dafür gebaut. Das ist eine eigene Ansteuerungsplatine. Da sind dann die Zeiltreiber drin. Und was die dann letzten Endes machen, davon habe ich dann für die 96 Stück in meiner Wand jeweils eine Platine. Und die sind über einen Datenbus miteinander verbunden, sodass ich von einem Hauptsteuerungcomputer aus die gesamte Kunstinstallation steuern kann.
Du hast gerade 96 Platinen gesagt?
Da waren tatsächlich ein paar manuelle Tasks bei dem Löten der Platine. Aber das waren nur sehr große Parts tatsächlich. Was mein Prototyping angeht, bin ich dazu übergegangen, die Platinen in China fertigen zu lassen. Und die bekommt man dort auch fertig bestückt zurückgeliefert. Jetzt warte ich gerade noch auf eine schnelle Express-Lieferung von dem Leiterplattenfertiger, damit ich noch ein paar verbliebene Panels, die gerade nicht funktionieren, in Betrieb nehmen kann. Aber da schafft es DRL tatsächlich seit drei Tagen. Sie haben es dreimal probiert, hier auf die Messe zu liefern, aber sie kriegen es nicht hin. Also DRL Express ist hier irgendwie problematisch auf dem Messegelände.
Die interne Post, die auf dem Kongress funktioniert, ist herzufällig, soll das jetzt da hin liefern lassen?
Ja, das hat tatsächlich sehr gut funktioniert. Da habe ich auch bereits ein Paket erhalten, das war wesentlich schneller da. Diese Lieferung aus China, die jetzt irgendwie schon seit fünf Tagen in Leipzig ist, das ist in der gleichen Stadt tatsächlich.
Hast du denn am Ende dir jetzt ein Tool gebaut oder geklickt durch ein Software, wo du drin malen kannst? Oder programmierst du deine Animation, ich sage mal, von Hand, indem du da Muster in Tabellen einträgst?
Aktuell ist die Software so gebaut, dass ich ein Tool habe, wo ich eine Abfolge von Bildern reinwerfen kann. Und aus diesen Bildern berechne ich mir dann eine Abfolge von Befehlen vorab, die ich mir dann auf die Disk speichere und die ich dann später in das Programm, was die Kunstinsulation ansteuert, reinladen kann, weil das nicht schnell genug wäre, das on the fly zu berechnen. Die Software ist recht langsam tatsächlich für den Steuerungskomputer. Ich habe tatsächlich mehr Zeit auf die Entwicklung der Firmware verbracht, damit ich halt, weil Firmware, die kannst du halt nicht so schnell austauschen, wie eine Software auf dem Steuerungs, auf dem Hauptcomputer, die kannst du halt ganz schnell austauschen. Dann merkst du halt scheiße, die Firmware hat irgendwie einen Bug oder da kann man irgendwie, wenn die Firmware im Moment Fehler hat, kannst du auch irgendwie die Boards durchbrennen lassen oder so was. Dann will man halt da irgendwie mehr Aufwand reinstecken. Und das ist halt jetzt so die Firma in einem Zustand, wo man halt, egal was man im Datenbus reingibt, das Ding brennt nicht durch. Und ja, die Firma dafür ist auch dokumentiert online. Die hat so, ja, verschiedene unterschiedliche Befehle, die man denn senden kann. Das heißt, ich sage irgendwie zu einem Panel, hier hast du einen Framebuffer, stell den mal da. Und was man auch machen kann, ist, ich kann sagen, wie schnell er das Display updaten soll. Das heißt, man kann mit unterschiedlichen Intervallen arbeiten, um mit dem ganzen Ding zu musizieren.
Ich hatte das vorher kurz als Frage im Kopf, aber das machst du tatsächlich auch. Also ich halte mal fest, du musst dafür löten können, Elektrotechnik programmieren, obviously. Du musst Ahnung von Musik haben und Animationen.
Bist du jetzt fertig?
Das mit der Ahnung von der Musik, das habe ich dann tatsächlich an Leute, die sich mit so was auskennen, ausgelagert. Genauso, was Produktionen von einem Video, von dieser Installation angeht. Aber insgesamt würde ich behaupten, dass dieses Flip-Dot-Projekt damit dann auch durchgespielt ist. Ich selber gebe die Installation hier nach ab, sehr wahrscheinlich an ein Kunstmuseum. Die werden dann so Richtung Karlsruhe gehen tatsächlich.
Was ich mich frage bei so einem großen Projekt, ich stelle mir immer vor, wenn man sozusagen bildende Kunst macht, also keine Ahnung, jemand, der eine Holzkultur geschnitzt hat, der hat dann das Werk seiner eigenen Hände vor sich und kann das dann irgendwo hinstellen, ist das auch so ein Gefühl? Weil ich habe bei allem, was irgendwie mit Digitalität zu tun hat, immer so diesen Verdacht von, das muss man dann irgendwie weiterverwenden können. Und das ist für dich jetzt einfach fertig.
Ja, es ist für mich fertig und das ist tatsächlich auch ein ganz schönes Gefühl, wenn man irgendwie so lange an so einem Projekt rumtüftelt, dann hinterher davor stehen zu können. Und was mich tatsächlich auch immer sehr freut, wenn Leute dann da rangehen und irgendwie hat jeder auch so dieses Bedürfnis, das Ding anzufassen, um zu verstehen, wie es funktioniert. Also das sind tatsächlich so Momente, wo man sich dann durchaus sehr freut. Für mich ist das Projekt dann tatsächlich auch so damit durch. Und ich denke mal, dass wenn das dann da in Karlsruhe irgendwo landet, dass ich dann da auch nochmal vorbeidüse und denen da noch irgendwie helfe und irgendwie gucke und vielleicht dann noch das ein oder andere, was jetzt hier auf dem Kongress aufgrund der Zeitknappheit irgendwie nicht mehr geklappt hat, da noch realisiere. Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen, ist das durchgespielt. Dann geht es weiter an andere Projekte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was machst du als nächstes?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also ich hätte mal Bock auf eine Lichtinstallation tatsächlich. Aber ich habe da noch gar keine konkreten Ideen.
Na gut, dann fragen wir vielleicht zum nächsten Kongress nochmal nach.
Mal schauen.
Sehr schön. Also man kann das heute und morgen noch hier auf dem Kongress gucken und dann ab wann in Graz Ruhr?
Da habe ich keine Ahnung. Also tatsächlich gar nicht. Ich weiß nur, für mich endet dieses gesamte Projekt erst mal am 5.1. Mit Übergabe der Panels an jemanden.
Anders gefragt, wo kann man dir wie folgen, damit man mitbekommt, wenn du verkündest, dass das jetzt öffentlich zu sehen ist?
Man findet mich unter meinem Namen Flippke auf diversen Medien.
Also F-L-U-E-P-K-I.
Genau, da werde ich das dann auch. Vielleicht auch ganz interessant, den ganzen Code und die Software findet man ebenfalls auf GitLab unter dem Namen. Also gitlab.com. Es gehen aber nicht alle Panels dahin. Einige gehen noch an den Verstehbarenhof zum Beispiel. Und noch so ein, zwei andere Leute, die mir sehr geholfen haben bei dem Projekt. Aber ansonsten sind sie tatsächlich alle weg.
Das heißt, wer auch immer das nachmachen will, muss jetzt selber anrufen bei ÖPNV. Ne, da sehe ich aber noch eine Frage. Du hast die Dinger jetzt von der BVG. Ja. Ist das eine Standardtechnologie? Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt keine Ahnung in Hamburg anrufe und die zufälligerweise auch so die Dinger rumliegen habe, dann ist die Chance groß, dass ich mit deinem Code was anfangen kann? Oder gibt es da irgendwie so viele Produkte, wie es öffentliche Nahverkehrsbetriebe gibt?
Da bin ich tatsächlich nicht so gut informiert. Also ich hab mich natürlich auch mit anderen Leuten unterhalten, die Flipdots machen. Da gibt es diverseste Ansteuerungen. Es gibt welche, die sind sehr viel eleganter auf einer technischen Ebene als das, was die BVG hier im Einsatz hat. Es gibt auch welche, so von Brose etwas, das ist wesentlich weniger elegant, wo man nur so einen Pixel at a time setzen kann. Und irgendwie dann so ein 60-Pin-Interface dazu hat. Hier sind es glücklicherweise nur 34, um irgendwie 230 Pixel zu steuern. Ja, also die BVG hat, soweit ich weiß, keine mehr. Also ich hab denen jetzt noch die Letzten, um hier kaputte Panels austauschen zu können, aus den Fingern geleuert tatsächlich. Fun Fact übrigens, die Idee war eigentlich, weil mich halt so viele Leute gefragt haben, wo hast du die her? Ich will auch irgendwie Flipdots haben. Also die Idee, okay, ich will jetzt mal irgendwie unters Volk werfen, so an Hacker-Spaces verteilen und an Hacker-Innen verteilen. Okay, wie macht man das dann irgendwie mit der Logistik? Und war halt so die Überlegung, das ist ganz schön teuer, die mit DIL zu verschicken. Also schlepp ich die einfach mal an zum Kongress, mach einfach mal so eine Batch-Order. Und dann, ja gut, 100 Flipdots am Kongress, da kann man auch irgendwie was mitmachen. Und dann ist daraus diese Kunstinstallation entstanden und eigentlich wollte ich die dann tatsächlich noch an einzelne Hacker, die in die Hand drücken, so zum Selbstkostenpreis. Und dann kam halt jemand vorbei und hat halt gesagt, Shut up and take my money, ich nehme hier einmal den ganzen Ladennetz, so sinngemäß. Ich mach damit jetzt keinen Gewinn, aber halt ist halt sehr viel stressreicher, dass irgendwie alles einem dann in die Hand zu drücken.
Damn, na gut, aber das heißt natürlich, hab ich auch sofort den Puls aus dem Ding zu Hause, wäre ich auch ganz schlecht, gar nicht schlecht. Na gut, aber dann nicht dieses Jahr, vielleicht ein andermal. Flipkipp, vielen Dank, dass du hier warst und uns die Flipdots gezeigt hast. Dankeschön. So. Wir müssen hier bald zum Ende kommen. Ich hatte ja am Anfang versprochen, ich werde jetzt was zur Zukunft des Chaosradios sagen. Wir haben heute kurz in der Redaktion gesprochen und es gibt folgende Idee. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr von Markovketten schon mal gehört habt. Das ist so ein Algorithmus, wo man Text analysieren kann und dann werden automatisch neue Texte daraus geworfen. Wir haben die Idee, jetzt alle alten Chaosradios zu transkribieren und das in so einen Markovketten-Generator reinzuwerfen. Daraus entstehen Texte und die durch Sprachsynthese zu vertonen und dann erscheinen also nächstes Jahr jeden Tag ein neues Chaosradio. Punkt. Nein. Tatsächlich wissen wir es immer noch nicht so genau. Es gibt den festen Vorsatz zu sagen, nächstes Jahr mehr Folgen als dieses Jahr. Dieses Jahr waren es zwei. ich kann auch noch erfreulich berichten, also wir haben eins, Komona hatte erzählt, sie hätten viele tausend Pads. Wir haben für diese Sendung nur eins gehabt. Da sind aber doppelt so viele Themen drin, wie wir jetzt gerade auf die Bühne gebracht haben und bei den anderen haben wir gesagt, eigentlich könnte man dazu doch eine Sendung machen. Na mal gucken, was 2020 so bringt. Das war es heute von uns, für euch vom 36. Chaos Communication Congress. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Und mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.